The A - Z of isms... orientalism.
The late academic, Edward Said,
developed the term orientalism
to describe how Europeans
portray the orient
as inferior, uncivilised
and all around weird.
But importantly, Said argued
this was also, simultaneously,
about defining Europe
as the orient's opposite -
superior, civilised
and all around wonderful.
The actual term 'the orient' refers
to the rising of the sun in the east
and comes from
the Latin word 'oriens'.
So we can think of orientalism
as Eastern-ism
or stereotyping of the East.
Orientalism then, is the form
of knowledge, in quotation marks,
that authorises and justifies
the assertion of Western power
over the East.
But what does this actually mean?
Orientalism acts like a pair
of glasses that distort your vision
and exaggerate cultural
and religious differences.
With these glasses,
just about everything and everyone
seems highly exotic and strange
or worse, fanatical and dangerous.
Women in the Middle East,
for example,
appear only as exotic -
a belly dancer -
or oppressed - a 'veiled woman' -
with no nuances in between.
And in the early 20th Century,
you might have seen men
portrayed as exotically romantic
or more recently as crazy
and fanatical, a terrorist,
and miss all the ordinary
human beings along the way.
Many Arabs, Muslims and Asians
embrace this controversial term
to describe the unique kind
of racism they experience.
Orientalism encapsulates, for many,
how their culture,
religion and ethnicity
are so often reduced to a stereotype,
causing their humanity to be
overlooked and culture misunderstood.
Isn't this just a form
of stereotyping then?
Well, yes and no.
Orientalism is about a much
broader set of power relations.
When the US government
views the Middle East
through orientalist glasses
it creates policies
with far-reaching consequences.
From outright war waged
on other countries
to imposing a travel ban
on whole groups of people.
Perhaps the trickiest thing
about orientalism
is that it's not fuelled by ignorance
or a simple lack of knowledge,
just the opposite.
It has historically
been produced as knowledge
by those in positions of power,
whether government officials,
religious figures, or the media.
For example when
President Trump stated,
"I think Islam hates us,
we can't allow people
coming into this country
who have this hated
for the United States."
He effectively characterised
the 1.6 billion Muslims worldwide
as anti-American.
Even today,
orientalism continues
because it is so ingrained
in how we see other peoples
and cultures that it goes unnoticed.
Even the term, 'The Middle East'
is considered to be orientalist,
because it standardises
a Western viewpoint
by referring to West Asia and North
Africa as the middle of the East.
Much of what counts as knowledge
about the Middle East
and parts of Asia
is still produced through those
distorting and reductive glasses.
And just like in the
18th and 19th Centuries,
orientalism remains powerful
because it shapes,
not just how people in the West
view the East,
but also  how they view themselves.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)